my week's going [ __ ] great i just had
my last stressful gig of the year
all right now the rest of them i can
just [ __ ] have a good time
and try not to get tackled while i do my
[ __ ] jokes
i like that people are saying do you say
you worried now do you think it's go are
you worried as the comedian that things
are gonna happen it's like no
these crazy people only seem to be
attacking black comedians in los angeles
all right
now i am in los angeles
but i am as white as a bed sheet
all right
and i'm proud of that and you can't take
that away from me or else that's reverse
something or other i think
it's a double standard
um
why can't i be proud of my alabaster
legs
god knows i pay for it every summer
dude look how [ __ ] white your legs
are i realize that dude your legs could
be president
um
anyway so last night
i i had to host a show for netflix
um
i hosted this show during the you know
they're having the big netflix comedy
festival here which has been [ __ ]
amazing all of these comedians that i've
been running into it's been such a great
time
you know when lunatics aren't you know
charging up at the stage
jesus christ did they [ __ ] that guy up
i think he has mental issues so there's
a part of me aside from the weapon that
i actually i saw this sadness in his
eyes
but jesus christ his [ __ ] arms look
like you know
you guys ever see toy story what sid
does to his toys that's what his arms
look like it was just uh
i don't know that kid needs help i hope
he gets help i hope he does but um
anyways
shout out to the [ __ ] that still
brought their cell phones in and still
filmed it's just [ __ ] ridiculous man
and you just can't do a show without
somebody filming it on some level i
don't know put your cell phones in the
bags and just sit there like adults is
that so [ __ ] hard no man i gotta film
it man
i gotta get likes man i gotta get some
friends on my [ __ ] account man